[Music]
thank you
oh
it's the video creating headlines around
the world as Britney Spears has shown
running up behind Victor wabanamya and
then being pushed away by his Security
in an Instagram post beerus claims that
she was trying to get Victor's attention
on Wednesday in Las Vegas when the San
Antonio Spurs security member allegedly
slapped her in the face
in her statement Spirits is asking for a
public apology and says that traumatic
experiences are not new to me
I recognized an athlete in my hotel
lobby as I was heading to dinner I later
went to a restaurant at a different
hotel and saw him again I decided to
approach him and congratulate him on his
success
sphera says that because of the loud
environment she tapped the NBA player on
the shoulder to get his attention adding
I simply tapped him on the shoulder to
security then backhanded me in the face
in front of a crowd nearly knocking me
down and causing my glasses off my face
she adds I get sworn by people all the
time in fact that night I was swarmed by
a group of at least 20 fans my security
team didn't hit any of them Speer says
that she has yet to receive a public
apology from the player his security or
the organization but she hopes to
receive one soon plumbanyama was in Las
Vegas to make his debut in the NBA
Summer League tonight yesterday during
practice he gave his version of the
events that took place I didn't see what
happened because I was walking straight
but a person grabbed me from behind not
the mushrooms
I don't know with how without misforce
though he also revealed that he had no
clue the fan was Spears first I was like
uh no you're joking about it yeah I was
ridiculous yeah but uh I didn't know
because at least here I never saw her
face spirit's husband Sam ascari took to
Instagram to share a statement writing I
can't imagine a scenario where an
unarmed female fan showing any kind of
excitement or appreciation for a
celebrity would cause her to be
physically assaulted much less being hit
in the face for tapping someone on the
shoulder and in a statement to E.T
regarding spirus claim the Las Vegas
Police say on July 5th 2023 at
approximately 11 pm LV MPD officers
responded to her property in the 3700
block of Las Vegas Boulevard regarding a
battery investigation the incident has
been documented on a police report and
no arrests or citations have been issued
no further details will be provided at
this time and later the Las Vegas
Metropolitan Police Department revealed
that an investigation into the
allegations concluded on Friday morning
and no charges will be filed
[Music]